[Music]
so let's take a look at financial
independence what that really means I
mean you know if you haven't thought
about it at all you just think oh that's
for rich people or I could never do that
or you know so first of all I'd like to
know I'd like to distinguish between
independence and freedom so financial
freedom is like freeing your mind
financial freedom is is understanding
that I me and there's an economy out
there and I have a relationship with it
but it doesn't run my life
you know it's freeing my mind from the
message of the messages of the consumer
culture the messages of the economy the
messages that you know a house is a
starter house no that's my house I could
die in my house you know it's like
there's so many presumptions that drive
us into wage slavery debt and it doesn't
matter whether you are at the low end or
the high end if you are engaged in that
sort of anxious process of more more
MORE
you are not free so the first layer of
financial independence I talked about is
this freedom of the mind is freeing your
mind of going saying like I am sovereign
the economy is secondary
I will move I will move my sovereign
self into the economy for my own
purposes rather than I am a slump in the
economy is my is my mega boss and I
don't know my boss seems to be as big as
the sky and so I will just let my life
be run by that my boss and the tax
system and I'm just gonna let myself be
run by this thing know so you are
sovereign beings so that's your first
layer of financial independence is your
own sovereignty and then the second
layer is to get out of debt and for some
people debt feels endless and the first
step to getting out of debt is stop
going into debt really you know it's
like and so there are many organizations
there's you know debtors anonymous
there's many ways that people can help
them with this addiction to constantly
spending and spending beyond their means
however you do that you just stop
increasing your debt and start whittling
your
way through it and with the approach in
your money your life I mean there's many
people have written to us who flatten
their debt in a couple years
impossible debt debt there was going to
be endless they would die with this debt
and once they see what the debt is doing
to them in terms of the actual
opportunities the future opportunities
of their lives once they see that once
they have a taste for yen for the kind
of sovereignty authenticity autonomy
freedom whatever you want to call it you
know mastery over your own time ability
to write your novel or take your sailing
cruise or play with your grandkids
whatever it is that you want more than
you want stuff you know that's what we
try that's the sort of link that we try
to to get people to make so that
something in the future is more
important than the immediate pleasure of
buying one more tchotchke that you're
never going to use we call them gazenga
spins the things you buy repeatedly and
you never use and they go into the
gazenga spin drawer and yet when you're
in the store you buy another one and
just look in your drawers take a look in
your closets you know you'll find them
so this yeah so getting flattening your
dad is the second level of financial
independence and the third level really
is to get those six months of savings in
liquid assets whether it's bank accounts
you know someplace where you can
actually within 24 48 hours you could
realize that money so that you have an
emergency fund so that you are you are
not tumbled back into debt as soon as
something happens amiss you lose a job
which you know many people now feel that
even they're very very important and
significant jobs are precarious so you
want to get out of the zone of
precariousness and part of how you get
out of that precariousness is savings
and then over time the next layer of
financial independence is is you start
to see that surplus savings can be
invested in such a way that it throws
off an income and over time if you
become a systemic and sometimes
so savor you know they're people who
save up to 80 or 90 percent of their
income you know whether it's in their
401k or you know the Roth IRAs and you
know there's all these instruments for
saving money you become a super saver
and you can see you could chart it you
can watch your passive income grow and
you can start to see because you track
your daily expenses basically the
mechanics of this whole thing are
knowing the money is your life energy
you track everything you buy and an easy
way to do it if you don't like you know
like writing a little notebook every
time you do a transaction is just use
your debit card I said debit not credit
you use your debit card in your bank has
a complete record of all your purchases
and then every month you take a look at
your purchases you sort it out in
categories that apply to your lifestyle
and then let's say you know you have a
category called shoes and you spend like
one hundred and fifty dollars or you
know let's say one hundred and sixty two
dollars on shoes and you know we have a
calculation that says my real hourly
wage all things considered it's not
thirty six dollars an hour it's nine
dollars an hour so nine you know I've
just spent X number of hours ten hours
of my life whatever on shoes and then
you ask your is this worth it to me
did it make me happy I'm like glad about
this purchase what I spend more on it
what I spend less on it no shame no
blame no like admonition no going and
confessing to your financial planner
just between you and your you know your
mint calm or whatever it is you just
look at that and you kind of tell
yourself the truth about whether
spending your life energy in that way
makes a difference that process gives
you a sense you develop a month in month
out year in year out sense of precisely
how much money it costs you to have a
happy life you have your happy life
number it's not you know some columnist
and the Washington Post blah blah
it's your happy life number it is I
spend 3,776 dollars month in month out
month in month out month in month out
month in month out more or less plus or
minus 10% and then you start to see your
income from your investments from your
savings line when that crosses when you
have three thousand seven hundred
seventy six whatever I said dollars in
passive income you realize you could let
go of the active income and live on that
amount of money so it's reality based
it's unique to you the only person who
knows what your number is is you some
people become fi on $700,000 some people
a million some people ten million some
people less you know some people
basically they get out of debt and they
have their six months of savings and
they have some basic income that the
bottom will never fall out and then they
travel around the world for three years
on bicycles you know it's all its
freedom it's like you're buying yourself
degrees of freedom through this
developing a habit of precise attention
to the flow of money and stuff in your
life
[Music]
you